we're going to get to the book but I
hear that you're also very passionate
about concerts like live concerts I am
all for this I hear that you want to
start up matina for concert here's what
I want to say the
Boomers I am let me just say something
I'm 65 years old and Mommy goes a bit
early so my point is simply this I don't
understand why and I always use them
Cold Play why don't they do a mattina
I'm like a one o00
concert wouldn't you go to a one even a
four even a four I'm down for a four
wait stop what time did you just say or
four four a concert is usually like
hours is like I'm getting in my pajamas
by four is
like sleep foreplay
sleep like it's like the before the
sleep I am down for a one as well I'm
just telling you the world is populated
by Boomers we're all going to die soon
and it would be nice to go to a concert
again I love music I live for music but
I'm not going to go to a thing that
starts at like I apparently you did a
concert in Vegas and you started at 9:30
oh no no no wait wait wait no here's the
thing no I did not no I did not no I did
not you know when I started 8:30 ma'am
and here's the thing I they asked me 930
83 they asked me I'm playing I'm playing
a New Year's Eve thing and literally
they gave me the option of well do you
want to be on stage when it goes
midnight or would you rather do like
your normal 8:30 and I was like it is
there a world in which someone chooses
to be singing at midnight I don't
understand it like I was yeah I'm I'm
forat name I'm just well whatever I'm
starting a movie join me I would love
to love
[Music]
that
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home